landscapes that appeared to dissolve
enormous screens where works by old
masters are deconstructed
they're all creations by da vida que
hora he comes from a family of artists
and grew up in Rome surrounded by the
cultural treasures the city is famous
for although the world of computing
captured cuales interest early on art
never lost its hold on him for me
historical artworks kind of icons of of
beauty and perfection in a way something
that we studied so much we looked at
them i'm interested in the contrast of
how such an old object could be looked
again in any ways his fascination with
the works of great artists like diego
velazquez has often brought qui Ola to
museums like the Museo del Prado in
Madrid both in real life and in the
digital world back in 2009 the Prado
posted high-resolution images of 14 of
its most important works online
meanwhile collaborations like the one
with Google Art Project have made it
possible to admire virtual versions of
works like Diego velasquez's thus many
nests the painting was the basis for
this animation by Toyota
this obviously a celebration of these
masterpieces is a reflection of my
interest doors this masterpieces but
that's also a reflection on how society
it's leaving this digital mediation in a
way are we are changing the way we look
at the world and therefore these objects
the tiger hunt by peter paul rubens was
also transformed into a work of abstract
art viola uses custom computer software
to study the paintings then he employs
algorithms he developed himself to
recalibrate the works exposing their
underlying geometric structure the
result combines classical art with a
digital aesthetic
my relationship with technology it's not
just as an instrument I think it's
almost like a collaborator I like to
develop tools that I can have an
exchange with it's almost the process of
discovery in itself working technology
so technology is not just there as a way
to serve an idea but rather as a way to
shape the idea itself to have a kind of
conversation at the factum artifice
ility in Madrid Kuala is working on a
new series of sculptures he's already
had solo shows in Berlin Moscow New York
and LA and is one a number of prizes at
festivals for electronic and digital art
his works are attracting increasing
attention from mainstream art dealers to
dr. marta is a pioneer in the use of new
technologies in addition to conservation
and reproduction work for institutions
like the British Museum the Louvre the
team also works directly with artists
anish kapoor marina abramovic and marc
quinn have all had installations
produced here dr. martha has many
different technologies at its disposal
ranging from 3d scanners to robots here
at factum I think what is very
fascinating is that both embrace new
technology and this kind of digital
fabrication pipelines with very
traditional finishing techniques or
let's say combination between these two
which I think really allows the
possibility to produce incredible things
in addition to his sculptures and Prince
qui Ola also works in other media his
next project a robot they can create
sculptures will appear at a live
performance in Berlin in quai odors work
the real and the digital are
complementary rather than contradictory
a lot of you know kind of younger
generation digital natives engaging a
lot with technology as a subject itself
to explore w I ollas art captures one of
the defining features of our age the
gradual merging of the virtual and the
real